>> CHRIS: Hi, I'm Chris and I'm interaction
designer with the Android project. Today,
I'm going to talk about my favorite feature,
the Window Shade. The Window Shade gives you
access to your notifications. Unlike most
platforms, the Android platform allows you
to, not only see your notifications in the
upper left-hand portion of the screen, but
actually act on them using the Window Shade.
So for example, I've received an SMS message.
I can just pull down the Window Shade and
automatically see, not only the SMS message,
but all of the items that have come in on
my device. I can see that I've downloaded
an application, received an instant message,
an e-mail, as well that SMS, and I can see
a calendar event is present as well. The difference
here is that these notifications are actionable
on the Android platform. So for example, I
can see that that instant message, I probably
should reply to that since that’s someone
I'm meeting with shortly. Simply tap that
message and start communicating via Google
Talk with that person.